the competition were a professional chef
and a mom cooked head-to-head preparing
the best dish possible featuring one
secret ingredient
our first competitor today is mom Greta
its minute I've been a mother for 29
years I ride for the police department I
do mounted patrol and I take care of a
ranch then normal mom stuff I've learned
a lot about cooking for kids because
they are so picky sometimes so you learn
all kinds of tricks I am a little
nervous going up against a real chef I
don't care what I have to do to it it's
gonna taste good just season the holy
heck out of whatever that secret
ingredient is make your pellet explode
in a good way if I won this my oldest
daughter who has two children I have to
bank you hopefully she'll learn
something from and competing against
Greta is professional chef Andrew gruel
my name is Andrew gruel on chef/owner of
SlapFish restaurant group in Southern
California we have over seven
restaurants and I've been cooking for
over 20 years our restaurant is
definitely kid-friendly we're actually
trying to get kids to eat more seafood
by making the dishes fun and whimsical
and you know really playful I do have a
five year old and I have a 15 month old
and I love cooking for kids because
interestingly their palates are so open
I'll definitely say I'm somewhat
apprehensive and nervous about today
because she's got three kids I'm a
relatively new father and that works for
my kids but that might not necessarily
work for everybody else's kids for me
it's about validation
I wouldn't mind putting this notch in
the belt welcome Greta chef Andrew today
you're gonna be competing to see who can
make the tastiest dish possible
featuring one secret ingredient in 30
minutes or less please let me introduce
our panel judges my favorite animal is
the lion - Brianna I'm 11 years old
my favorite animal is a squirrel my name
is also Andrew I'm 25 years old and my
favorite animal is the pig I think it's
time to find out what the secret
ingredient is Oriana will you please
take the lid off I've ever had tofu no
this is like a substitute for me instead
of pork or shrimp you have like little
pieces of tofu yeah here's one you pick
up one of those
I can't explain what it feels like do
you cook with tofu at home not on
purpose when I found out it was tofu it
totally threw me for a loop I've just
never dealt with it before I don't
really have that much experience with
tofu I think I cooked with it in
culinary school definitely not a tofu
expert even playing fields
I guess so I'll be the only tofurkey
here okay chefs whatever you cook today
will have to feature tofu yes you have
30 mins to cook and your time starts
yeah hey watch yourself gotta get the
good stuff here yeah baby I need to
figure out the template upon which I
build something that's fun that I know
the kids are gonna like beloved tofu
tofu is very jiggly I don't care for the
texture that kind of slimy feel my
strategy is gonna be just hide it as
much as possible and they won't have to
know that it's really healthy for all
those times I made fun of my vegetarian
friends I feel that this is the
redemption so I've got tofu to work with
and hamburger beef now he'll make tacos
kids love tacos and a little chili
powder yeah baby I know that as a kid
growing up I love BLT bacon lettuce and
tomato who doesn't love bacon it could
be my secret ingredient right here so
I'm gonna start cutting up my bacon I'm
gonna get that into the pan I'm gonna
slowly render it oh stop with the fancy
coulis oh you gotta show it off a little
bit I could try that all right I don't
think they'd want to pick it up off the
floor
I've got spinach and I've got some
lettuce and the one thing that I know
kids love about a salad is croutons what
do I see potato chips oh my god there we
go how about I triple bread and fry the
tofu and I actually bread it in the
potato chips getting into the fried
stuff low calorie just over there I
stick the tortillas in the toaster so
while that's heating I'm gonna dice my
onions my tomatoes my lettuce and grade
my cheese I feel like this salad is
still gonna be somewhat one-dimensional
if I don't add another ingredient to it
so I'm running over back to the pantry I
look in the refrigerator and what do I
see eggs I can't think of a kid that
doesn't like eggs so I'm gonna fry the
eggs in the bacon fat I'm think I might
actually just end up frying my whole
dish chef's you have 15 minutes
remaining halfway there chef
this is a little site of reef I'd tofu
beans right now I'm making my version of
a ranch dressing I'm adding a little bit
of cream cheese never go wrong with
cheese I'm adding some fresh herbs and
adding Dijon mustard
to cut through some of that richness
want to go see what he's doing over
there and I'm gonna check in on mom
Greta all right hey guys looks like
you're working pretty hard on your dish
please tell me you like bacon keeping it
simple you know with a salad trying to
bring it back to my 11 year old self and
that ranch this is better than ranch
it's all homemade right there
everything's better homemade Thank You
chef Andrew we will be looking forward
trying to dish looking forward to
serving you hey Greta yes just checking
in on how things are going so what was
your strategy coming in with tofu
everybody loves a taco especially kids
right incorporate a little tofu in there
is this something that you've made in
the past or do do you think the trophy
is gonna complement things I sure hope
so let's hope so
all right we'll let you get to it thank
you wondering if this is all gonna cook
in time I'm not gonna lie chef's you
have five minutes remaining times almost
up yeah I mean tofu so now I've got my
tofu in the beef so I'm gonna top them
off and I got to get my lettuce cuz I'm
going to garnish and make it look
pleasant avocado tomato and slice my
bananas and I'm gonna Surprise them with
a banana honey peanut butter taco one
minute left
make your final preparations I look down
on the plate and I realized that those
tots need dressing on them so I'm
rushing through with a spoon to get that
last bit of dressing on the top
hmm Greta chef Andrew welcome back a
little tight there
Greta can you please present your dish
everybody loves tacos right yes there's
some tofu in there and if you notice the
one on top has bananas honey and peanut
butter in a nice healthy toasted
tortilla one two three
I like it you can't taste the tofu you
can taste the means which is really good
because it means are actually amazing
kind of makes sense amongst the being I
thought I was gonna be like kind of like
flavorful but like tofu doesn't really
like taste like anything to me yeah
Thank You Greta you're welcome I think
we're gonna move on to chef Andrews dish
chef Andrew can you please describe this
dish
I love BLT it's its iconic I incorporate
all these ingredients into the salad
potato chips crusted around the tofu
croutons my version of a ranch dressing
and fried eggs in the bacon fat 3 okay
one actually gonna like it especially
with the ranch mm-hmm it makes a lot of
sense
I don't really like the milk but this
one is really good feels like a healthy
breakfast like someone on a diet would
eat this I wouldn't be too sure about
that
Thank You chef Andrew your dishes were
both really amazing we have a lot to
discuss please give us a moment to
decide great dish actually reminds me of
home we have tacos every once in a while
it was very decorative and had a taco
and had dessert she kind of took the the
route of hiding the tofu and everything
so we really wanted tofu because that
was their secret ingredient it tasted
amazing though we all found it really
tasty I'm still trying to read the kids
faces I thought you got really creative
with those little tofu balls because I
was looking at your dish and I'm
thinking to myself I want to shove that
in my mouth maybe that's the 11 year old
in me can you give me details like if
you like paper Andrews I like the idea
of the BLT salad cause it gives it a
little more flavor I have never had a
coated tofu before it was really smart
is that he use potato chips the fried
egg did kind of feel like an
afterthought this is a tough thing thing
is I think you might have taken at home
with the dessert but I'm feeling pretty
confident about my tofu balls
of course I hope it's me but you know
I'll be a gracious loser I think we know
who the winner is yeah I think we do
let's get them back in here
Greta chef Andrew thank you both for
coming in today could some really
amazing dishes unfortunately we can only
have one winner
Greta your dessert taco was really good
it was a nice surprise on the plate chef
Andrew we thought your salad BLT was a
very creative choice and the winner of
mom versus chef is chef Andrew good
night these kids have poker faces better
than seasoned professionals I was really
surprised ah I really thought I had a
good chance at this but I was impressed
my hat's off to him
this is the best judging panel right
here I come from a restaurant mentality
so kind of had to flip things upside
down on their head a little bit when I
go home tonight yeah I might be bragging
a little bit in front of the kids
no more saying my food doesn't taste
good both scream dishes were truly
amazing this has been mom versus chef
what ingredient should we do next time
taffy
oh yeah